britney spears
is celebrating her release from her
conservatorship
the hashtag free brittany campaign
by tweeting out a fully nude photo of
herself or i suppose posting it to
instagram
the caption reads quote free woman
energy has never felt better
and i'm beginning to think maybe this
free britney campaign was not such a
great idea after all
12 year old michael i'm sure is furious
right now with
31 year old michael for complaining
about a naked photo of britney spears
that's probably that's probably true but
i have to complain about it because this
is
not a great idea
it actually does undermine the free
britney argument because this is pretty
strange
wacky self-destructive behavior now
britney spears is a pop star and pop
stars do these sorts of things so it's
not completely out of the ordinary but
the purpose of a conservatorship
is to put some constraints on people's
autonomy and individual choices because
they are not capable of handling their
freedom right maybe it's because you've
got some mental problem maybe it's
because you've got a drug problem
but
the idea behind a conservatorship is not
to take away your freedom but actually
to protect your freedom from your own
basis desires and your own basis
inclinations which will
destroy your freedom
it gets down to this argument that we're
having on the right right now about what
freedom really is
and the libertarians
are saying that i i'm painting with
something of a broad rush but generally
the libertarians are saying freedom is
the ability to do whatever you want
whenever you want to do it if i want to
do drugs and and sleep around and have
all sorts of self-destructive behaviors
that's my freedom
and the conservatives are saying no
freedom isn't the ability to just do
whatever you want whenever you want to
do it
freedom is the right to do what you
ought to do
so for the libertarian point of view the
modern liberal point of view
freedom is the heroin addict shooting up
heroin but the conservative knows that
the heroin addict is not free he's
actually a slave to his own basis
desires
if
if a society
treats its freedom as an excuse to just
get naked
and
dance around and
do a bunch of drugs and sleep around and
abuse liberty to licentiousness in the
words of our founding fathers then we're
not going to stay free for very long
that that kind of people is not capable
of freedom
and so some guardrails are going gonna
have to be put on their individual
choice
and that's what you're seeing happen in
your government i don't really care that
much about the britney spears story in
and of itself but i care about the
political
significance of it
what we have done
as a people in recent decades
is
strip naked and post a bunch of pictures
of ourselves on instagram literally in
many cases but figuratively and as well
we have abused our freedom to
licentiousness we've proven ourselves
incapable of freedom in many instances
we can't even really conduct elections
anymore
no one trusts the result of our national
elections anymore democrats didn't trust
2016 republicans don't trust 2020.
democrats don't trust 2
000. we can't we we've torched our
cities over the past year
and by we i mean leftists have torched
the cities over the past year we don't
we don't we can't defend our national
borders we can't educate ourselves we're
not and so what's going to happen
inevitably
is someone is going to impose order from
without if we are not capable of freedom
then someone else is going to impose
order from outside
that's the way it goes here i'm so glad
you liked that clip
if you want to catch the whole show then
you got to subscribe ring the bell get
the notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe maybe leave a five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you